farbig vielleicht die erste Frage an Sie
sie haben ich habe das eben kurz
beschrieben dieses Manifest zunächst mal
mit 68 anderen mitunterzeichnet sich
eine Woche später davon distanziert
sagten dann im Vorfeld ich gehe da nicht
hin waren jetzt aber trotzdem da warum
und dass man auf Manifest und die Demo
sind ja zwei Dinge ich habe das Manifest
unterzeichnet weil ich der Auffassung
bin dass die Stimme von denen die für
Verhandlungen sind und gegen immer mehr
Waffenlieferung als eindimensionale
Lösungsstrategie in dem Krieg gegen die
Ukraine dass diese Stimmen zu wenig
vernehmbar sind zu leise sind und auch
politisch zu wenig Unterstützung fanden
und deswegen habe ich das unterschrieben
ich bin im übrigen von Frau Schwarzer
angefragt worden dass Frau Wagenknecht
dabei ist habe ich dann einen Tag vorher
Veröffentlichung erfahren aber
davon erfahren hätten dann hätten sie
gar nicht unterschrieben gut man kann
jetzt sagen ich habe es gewusst aber ich
habe das nicht richtig sozusagen
eingeordnet mit Frau Schwarzer hätte ich
es lieber gemacht als mit vorwagenknecht
warum erklären sie mal den Unterschied
weil ich nicht gewissermaßen in eine
politische Diskussion vereinnahmt werden
möchte und das ist dann alles in einen
Topf gerührt worden ich habe nichts
gegen die Linkspartei aber die hat das
rechte ihre Meinung zu sagen aber ich
bin kein
lieblingsfragenknecht ist eine Person wo
ich jetzt sage das ist in Ordnung was
sie macht aber ich möchte nicht
unbedingt den Eintopf gerührt werden ich
habe das Manifest aber trotzdem
unterzeichnet weil ich das inhaltlich
richtig finde im übrigen ist das kein
Manifest zwingend gegen Waffenlieferung
sondern gegen eine Eskalation von
Waffenlieferung das ist ein Unterschied
und vor allen Dingen und das war mein
zentrale Motivation für Verhandlungen
für mehr politische Energie in
Verhandlungen und dann hat sich das
entwickelt in dem Manifest dass
zunehmend auch Persönlichkeiten das
unterschrieben haben nicht als erste
Unterzeichner sondern als Unterstützer
dann am Ende mit denen ich nun wirklich
nichts zu tun haben möchte AFD
Funktionäre Leute wie Hero Faller
anderen mehr die nicht erst
Unterzeichner waren das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen
anspruchsvoll zu vermitteln dass es ein
Unterschied ist ob man erst
Unterzeichner also gewissermaßen mit
initiator ist oder Unterzeichner dann
einer Petition und das haben 620.000
Leute oder noch mehr unterzeichnet und
mit solchen Leuten wollte ich eben nicht
in einem Namen genannt werden und ich
hatte den Eindruck und das war das
entscheidende Momentum bei mir dass die
Initiatoren also Frau Schwarzer und vor
Wagenknecht nicht ernsthaft genug sich
von rechts abgegrenzt haben im Vorfeld
dieser Demonstration und da habe ich für
mich gesagt nein ich muss mich noch mal
ernsthaft prüfen und man kann das als
wankelmutigkeit bezeichnen man kann es
aber auch bezeichnen als Ringe mit sich
selbst ich bin dafür dass wir mehr
Energie Verhandlungen setzen und ich
will natürlich nicht mit jedem mich
gemein machen der das auch fordert
insofern muss man schon Grenzen ziehen
aber mir war es wichtig diese Stimme in
der Öffentlichkeit zu packen und
deswegen weil ich das Argument richtig
ist dann kann es ihnen doch am Ende oder
muss es eben sogar egal sein
optinocopala mit unterzeichnet richtig
das ist auch egal in dem Sinne als das
wenn man seinen Beifall davon abhängig
macht wer mit applaudiert dann ist man
völlig handlungsunfähig das ist also
nicht das entscheidende Argument man
wird nie verhindern können dass eine
richtige Sache auch falsche Leute in
Anführungsstrichen unterstützen was man
aber tun kann ist sich wenn man ein
politisches Statement macht und dieses
Manifest für Frieden war und ist ein
politisches Statement dass man sagt wen
möchte man nicht als Unterstützer und
das war mein Vorwurf an Frau Wagenknecht
und Frau Schwarzer dass sie da etwas
Waage geblieben sind der Satz der mich
geärgert hat jeder der reinen Herzens
ist kann da mitmachen das hat mich
gestört ich möchte nicht mit rechten
selbst wenn sie in der Frage rein Herzen
sind in einer Reihe genannt werden
Unterscheidung gemacht und haben gesagt
also weil er nicht einfach so ein
Mitunterzeichner sondern mit Initiator
genau
einen Tag vorher vor Schwarzer hat ich
sage das so wie es ist Frau Schwarzer
hatte mich angefragt mit anderen Worten
gelingt das ist ein großes Wort wegen
der politischen Himmelsrichtung ja Frau
Schwarzer hat mich jedenfalls angefragt
ich habe zugesagt einen Tag vor
Veröffentlichung hat Frau schwarze mir
eine Mail geschickt das jetzt auch Frau
Wagenknecht dabei ist ich hätte
zurückziehen können ich habe man da
nicht irgendwie überfallen oder so aber
ich habe vielleicht dann an dem Punkt
nicht gut genug nachgedacht das muss ich
jetzt gerade so und dann wollten sie
nicht hin und wann dann doch da ich
wollte hin um mir anzuschauen was daraus
geworden ist und ich wollte sehen ob
auch auf dieser Demonstration
gewissermaßen a von den Rednerinnen und
Rednern im Trüben gefischt wird und was
da überhaupt für ein Milieu ist und dann
muss ich ihn folgendes sagen ich habe
ich habe gesehen dass da ganz normale
Bürgerinnen und Bürger demonstrieren ich
was über saukalt in Berlin man musste
schon leidensfähig sein und zu dieser
Demo zu gehen es hat geschneit ich habe
mich in die Mitte gestellt und gehorcht
wer da so ist
und ich habe besorgte Bürgerinnen und
Bürger gesehen und im übrigen die Reden
von Frau Wagenknecht von Frau Schwarzer
auch von General Fahrt die waren für
mich alle in Ordnung alle haben sich
deutlich gegen Rechts abgegrenzt und
haben gute politische Punkte gemacht
jetzt kann man sagen ja einer Demo sind
manchmal auch schrille Töne das war auch
in den Reden so aber gesehen
diese Panzer Attrappe das habe ich auch
den Kontext oder so hergestellt habe ich
auch gesehen fand ich auch nicht in
Ordnung aber manche in Ordnung oder
total daneben komplett Banane total
daneben komplett Banane genau ja aber
ich kann Ihnen sagen ich war ja da ich
weiß nicht ob sie da waren aber ich war
da genau ich habe da keine großen
rechts rechtsradikalen Grüppchen oder
sowas gesehen sondern es waren Rechte da
ne ja das kann man nicht verhindern und
das wird natürlich medial jetzt
hochgezogen und dann werden einzelne
Personen da rausgesucht da waren
wahrscheinlich 20 30 000 Leute und das
da Figuren sind die da nicht willkommen
sind das ist sicherlich so aber die
Grundstimmung 30.000 also es ist
interessant weil die Zahlen
differieren ja ich habe sie nicht
gezählt die Polizei sagt 13,000,000
das wird irgendwas in der Mitte sein
denke ich das können wir doch von allen
Demos schon beim Bonner Hofgarten da
Sachen die Veranstalter in 80er Jahren
da war eine Hal Millionen und vielleicht
waren es dann 300.000 oder so ist aber
auch egal was der Punkt ist der Lanz da
hat die bürgerliche Mitte demonstriert
und nicht irgendwelche querfronten oder
Sektierer oder Radikale und die
politische Mitte wird in diesem Lande
und das muss ich leider sagen diffamiert
Herr Münkler ein geschätzter Kollege von
mir sagt das ist gewissenlos dieses Mal
nicht fest wo kommen wir denn dahin dass
Leute die besorgt sind die sich für
Frieden aufsprechen die nicht naiv sind
gegenüber Putin wenn Sie das Manifest
lesen das ist klar wer Opfer und wer
Täter
das finde ich gar nicht schon also ich
habe das also finde das ist das was mir
besonders im Kopf geblieben ist stoppt
die Eskalation der Waffenlieferungen
genau dachte ich sie meinen Putin im
ersten Moment wie sich dann gemerkt habe
aber ich glaube Putin das sind doch
wohlfeile Forderungen dass ich dafür bin
dass Putin diesen verbrecherischen Krieg
stoppt das können sie mir abnehmen
natürlich
dafür sind wir alle und wir haben jetzt
nicht irgendwie eine Situation wo man
nur mitspielen darf wenn man das am
Anfang noch mal ganz deutlich sagt das
ist selbstverständlich ich kenne
überhaupt niemanden der nicht der
Auffassung ist das Putin diesen
verbrecherischen Angriffskrieg stoppen
will die Frage ist doch wir richten uns
an eine deutsche Öffentlichkeit mit
diesen Manifest und da muss die
Forderung an die eigene Seite gehen das
ist doch völlig selbstverständlich und
das ist überhaupt keine Verharmlosung
von irgendwas oder keine klare
Positionierung dass Manifest ist
eindeutig in der Verurteilung Russlands
und wenn das nicht so wäre dann wäre ich
garantiert nicht am Anfang dabei gewesen
ja unlautererweise tatsächlich mit den
vorhandenen Ängsten in Deutschland auch
spielt weil sie haben natürlich Recht
die Mehrheit der deutschen Bevölkerung
spricht gar nicht gerne über Waffen
möchte auch keinen Krieg hat Ängste
möchte lieber Frieden und deswegen würde
ich auch sagen wir haben in den
vergangenen Monaten viel zu viel über
Waffen nur diskutiert und viel zu wenig
über den Konflikt an sich was dahinter
steckt wie man ihn lösen kann da bin ich
ganz bei ihm aber es geht ja nicht darum
entweder das eine oder das andere zu tun
sondern eigentlich müssen wir ja den
Fokus darauf richten dass die
Waffenlieferungen die Voraussetzungen
sind für Verhandlungen eine
Verhandlungslösung wird ja erst in dem
Moment geben dem Herr Putin keinen Sinn
mehr darin sieht weiterzukämpfen das ist
das Ziel dieser Aufrüstung der Ukraine
und was sie vorschlagen ist ja wir
müssen auf ein Putin zugehen dass es
unrealistisch von ihm zu fordern dass er
bitte seine Truppen abzieht und weil das
unrealistisch ist gehen wir gleich mit
einem Kompromiss auf ihn zu sagen Land
für Frieden das sind ihre Worte Land
gegen Frieden er kann bitte ein Fünftel
der Ukraine haben wenn er danach
friedlich ist und das ist natürlich eine
Illusion die Frage ist es dann ein
Fünftel ist es ein Zehntel ist es ein
Drittel also wo hört es auf und fängt es
an und dieses Manifest macht er
überhaupt keinen Vorschlag für was ist
denn überhaupt ein konkreter
verhandlungspunkt an dem wir an diesem
Punkt nach einem Jahr Krieg stehen und
man beginnt ja so auch keine Verhandlung
mit dem Ergebnis mit einem potenziellen
Ergebnis
sagen ja ich habe keine Angst aber ich
finde wir sollten Verantwortung über
Unternehmen und verantwortung heißt in
dieser brenzlichen Situation keine
Ängste zu schüren aber doch die Dinge
klar zu benennen wir sind in einer
Situation wo dieser Krieg jeden Tag
Tausende Opfer bringt schwerste
Verwerfungen in der Ukraine und weltweit
anrichtet und wir haben die
Verantwortung wir heißt dann in erster
Linie die politischen Gestalter ich bin
nur ein Analytiker ich kann nichts
gestalten leider vielleicht aber ich
kann nur sozusagen meine Stimme erheben
ich finde die Politiker haben die
Verantwortung sich Gedanken darüber zu
machen wie wir aus diesem Krieg wieder
rauskommen und mit eindimensional immer
mehr Waffenlieferungen werden wir nichts
erreichen das ist am Ende finde ich
sogar eine zynische Strategie die auf
dem Rücken der ukrainischen Soldaten
austrägt dass dieser Krieg eigentlich
von der entsprechenden
und wir kennen das so ist habe ich noch
kurz sagen wir haben eigentlich nur zwei
Szenarien das eine ist wir befeuern mit
unseren immer härteren Waffen Lieferung
ein dauerhaften abnutzungskrieg der
keine Seite gewinnen kann das sagen
viele Beobachter insbesondere der
amerikanische kanalstabschef viele
amerikanische Studien sagen dass ein
dauerhafter abnutzungskrieg der keine
Seite gewinnen kann und das andere ist
dass dieser Krieg eskaliert und das kann
bis hin zu einer nuklearen
Auseinandersetzung gehen auch wenn das
nicht sehr wahrscheinlich ist und jede
Lösung
sind unterhalb dieser beiden Szenarien
ist besser das heißt wir können
mit dieser Krieg wird ohnehin nur mit
Verhandlungen beendet und dann ist es
besser ihn früher oder zu beenden als
ihn später zu beenden und darüber muss
der Druck gehen und ich bin nicht naiv
das ist mit Putin einfach ist oder der
uns verschenken will überhaupt nicht
aber wir müssen darüber reden wie das
politisch gehen
ist schon unruhig und weil sie gerade
Politiker ansprechen da sitzen in einer
Kinder
ganz gelassen ich finde es zynisch zu
sagen das Waffenlieferungen
eindimensional sein weil er im Vorfeld
sehr viel verhandelt wurde und Putin hat
die Verhandlung mit Kriegsverbrechen vom
Tisch gewischen zynisch finde ich es
auch zu sagen die gesellschaftliche
Mitte Chemie nicht zu Wort wenn sie
Umfragen anschauen über die Hälfte der
Bevölkerung 59% sagt wir müssen mehr tun
als die panzerlieferung angeht sagt über
die Hälfte knapp dafür eine andere
deutliche Hälfte dagegen aber insgesamt
ist unsere Bevölkerung und das ist die
wirtschaftliche Mitte eindeutig dafür
zynisch ist übrigens auch wenn sie in
ihrer Manifest verlangen dass die
Ukraine Zugeständnisse machen muss weil
sie eben sagen beide Seiten müssen sich
aufeinander zu bewegen wir haben hier
Täter die angegriffen haben und wir
haben ein Land das souveräne Grenzen von
1991 von 2013 hat das seit 2014 im Krieg
ist wo das Rote Kreuz spricht von 13.000
bis 300.000 verlässliche Zahlen sind
knapp 100.000 Kinder entführt wurden mit
neuem Namen mit neuem Geburtsdatum in
Russland freigegeben worden zu Adoption
ich will nur deutlich machen die Waffen
waren ja erst ein weiterer Schritt es
wurde am Anfang massiv verhandelt und
Milli und Studien zu zitieren ist falsch
Milly hat gesagt Russland ist auf dem
Weg zu verlieren und wir müssen uns
einen klar sein wir denken immer wie
Russland handeln könnte wir müssen
deutlich sagen wir brauchen selber eine
Eskalation Strategie Abzug der
Nuklearwaffen aus Kaliningrad Anzug der
russischen Truppen aus Transnistrien
dass sie etwas größeres und sehr
deutlich machen wenn Russland wirklich
den Frieden will dann sollen sich
zurückziehen und die Ukraine kann erst
dann verhandeln wenn sie ihr souveränes
Gelände wieder hatten für was soll sie
verhandeln für die Begleichung der
Reparationen also der Kriegsschäden für
die Aufarbeitung der Kriegsverbrechen
und für Sicherheitsgarantien und für all
das steht ihr Manifest nicht und
deswegen habe ich mich mit Kollegen mit
Adrian Steffens und anderen entschieden
einen ja Entwurf zu machen der ich
glaube balancierter die Lage betrachtet
sie wollten gerade ich habe noch ein
ganz anderer Gedanke durch den Kopf ich
hatte das Gefühl schon neulich als wir
das hier Sarah Wagenknecht saß da haben
wir sehr intensiv darüber gesprochen was
sie eigentlich treibt vielleicht kann
die Regie noch mal das Bild zeigen dass
wir eben im Hintergrund hatten oder
möglicherweise auch die die Bilder die
Bewegtbilder von dieser
Friedensdemonstration am Wochenende was
man sieht was auffällt beim schwenke
über diese ganzen Leute ich weiß nicht
ob ihnen das so so aufgefallen ist als
sie dort waren vielleicht bei den
Bewegtbilder werden jetzt noch mal
deutlicher wenn man diesen Schwenk hier
sieht ich sehe weit und breit keine
einzige ukrainische Fahne
die Ukraine spielt komischerweise in
diesen Debatten in diesen Petitionen in
diesem Briefen es geht immer nur um
unsere Befindlichkeit es geht um unseren
nationalen unseren deutschen Blick auf
dieses Thema aber ich sehe keine da
sehen wir was ganz am Vortag die gab es
am Vortag genau ich weiß aber wir sehen
dazu keine ukrainische Fahrt geht es
ihnen wirklich um die Ukraine oder warum
geht eigentlich sie können das
anzweifeln in der lands aber mir
persönlich fragen nach meiner Motivation
ich kann nicht für andere sprechen aber
natürlich geht es mir um die Ukraine und
es geht nicht um meine Bequemlichkeit
ich bin in einer privilegierten Position
so oder so das ist nicht von dem Ausgang
dieses Krieges abhängig mir geht es
ausschließlich darum um zwei Dinge
eigentlich erstens dass die Ukraine
möglichst gut aus diesem Krieg rauskommt
und zweitens das muss ich auch deutlich
sagen dass Russland diesen Krieg nicht
gewinnt und nicht das politische Signal
entsteht dass man sich einfach mal so
Landstrich empfohlen kann mit
militärischer Gewalt und gut dabei weg
warum Stände denn die Ukraine ohne diese
Hilfe dann hätte sich doch Russland
genau dieses Land geholt und oder was
glauben Sie was wäre passiert
zu kämpfen dann hört sie morgen auf zu
existieren da sehen uns doch einig oder
nicht da sind wir uns einig aber die
andere Alternative die wir auch in die
Debatte bringen da sind wir uns einig ja
also die hören auch von mir auch nicht
geliefert gehören ja dann hat die
Ukraine auf zu existieren wenn wir uns
da einig sind ja was ist denn was ist
denn deine egal trotzdem weitermachen
und das ist ein wichtiger Punkt den sie
machen natürlich in den Manifest und ich
bin jetzt hier nicht der Autor des
Manifest aber sie fragen nach meiner
Position aber selbst in den Manifest
steht nicht dass wir heute jede
Waffenlieferung beenden müssen sondern
die Eskalation der Waffenlieferung
beenden das heißt das was rodrig viel
besser so schön beschreibt er will
Kampfflugzeuge das waren tabu und ist
immer noch unter Bruder Bundeskanzlerin
mir wird das nicht geben wenn wir morgen
kampfflug zugeschicken dann stellt sich
übermorgen die Frage einer
Flugverbotszone und überübermorgen von
eigenen deutschen Soldaten das heißt wir
sind auf eine Rutschbahn in einem Krieg
mit Russland und das will ich nicht ich
möchte aber der rote Linie farbig Wissen
an nur einer verstehen also Leopard 2
noch okay oder die Panzerhaubitze
Ihre Frage war was ich will und ich will
politische Lösung und ich bin davon
überzeugt dass wir sie mit immer mehr
Waffenlieferung nicht alleine erreichen
das heißt die These die sie vertreten
und die in der deutschen Öffentlichkeit
relativ populär ist dass wir mit immer
mehr Waffenlieferungen die Ukraine
bewegen diesen Krieg zu gewinnen die
teile ich nicht ne Ukraine wird gewinnen
wenn wir eine politische Lösung bekommen
beitragen das will ich gar nicht
bestreiten aber wir werden
Russland nicht militärisch besiegen
können und wir werden es glaube ich
nicht nein aber auch nicht so besiegen
können dass sie die Russen sich aus dem
Don Bass zurückziehen und aus der Krim
wenn Sie das Ziel ist der Ukraine wenn
dann in ukrainischer Perspektive Frieden
ist dann wird es so bald keinen Frieden
geben und ich bin sehr dafür dass wir
eine politische Strategie machen die
sich an realistischen Zielen orientiert
die Ukraine sollen möglichst gut aus
diesem Krieg rausgehen was heißt das
aber Russland darf nicht scheitern in
der Ukraine
hunderttausende tote wenn man nicht
zerstörtes Land richtig genau aber doch
bisherigen Strategie die bösen
Amerikaner das war einzigartig mit einer
der größten Transatlantiker diese nur
finden können also äh aber
nennen Sie doch mal klar wo denn die
Position für Verhandlung gerade liegen
kann weil ich glaube doch dass Einigkeit
darüber besteht wenn wir
Waffenlieferungen jetzt einstellen dann
ist nicht der Krieg verloren sondern
dann hört die Ukraine auf zu existieren
und außerdem für Einstellung der
Waffenlieferung ich bin dafür dass wir
nicht weiter eskalieren dass wir in
dieser Rutschbahn in die rodeich
käsewetter mit besten Wissen ich
unterstelle Ihnen überhaupt nichts
ich habe sie noch gute Motivation wir
wollen der Ukraine helfen ich aber auch
aber Russland eskaliert nicht unsere
natürlich
sehr sehr gute Frage gestellt
beantworten sie dir doch mal das war
schon eine falsche Prämisse ich bin
nicht für die Einstellung machen
Lieferung entschuldigung das müssen wir
doch sauber bleiben sondern
Eskalation
präzise sein und die Frage ist wie
könnte eine politische Lösung aussehen
genau
eine politische Lösung ich glaube eine
politische Lösung könnte nur so aussehen
wenn wir Russland auch ermöglichen seine
kerninteressen zu wahren und das kann
Interesse ist doch die Ukraine sich
gemein zu machen und dass die Ukraine
aufhört so souverän zu existieren wie
sie heute existiert
das sind jetzt ganz viele Dinge auf
einmal diese These dass er nicht stoppt
da können wir besonders diskutieren aber
die Frage ist was eine politische Lösung
sein kann
die liegt doch auf der Hand die wird aus
zwei Elementen bestehen und da müssen
wir hin erstens die Ukraine wird nicht
eindeutig in ein westliches
Militärbündnis integriert werden müssen
werden können weil das für Russland
einfach eine rote Linie ist die wir
nicht überschreiten können das ist ein
Teil der vorhaltig in die Nato und auch
keine
amerikanisches Militär das gehört
zusammen das ist die eine Teil der
politischen Lösung und der zweite Teil
der politischen Lösung ist dass wir
diese territoriale Frage also Krim und
Don Bass vermutlich nicht in unserer
Generation lösen können und deshalb
einfrieren müssen
die Ukraine auf Gelände verzichtet ja
und das können
frei kämpfen
wir können der Ukraine nicht zumuten
dass sie bei diesen Opfern auf Ihre
vollständige Souveränität verzichtet
denn das würde eine Folge haben das
andere Länder die aggressiv sind sagen
Angriffe lohnen sich Stichwort China
Taiwan irgendetwas bleibt immer Hafen
das ist das zweite ist 14
seit 2014 der führt ihn ja auch in
Syrien und er führte den Krieg in
Tschetschenien und das sind alles
Rollenmodelle gewesen um das
durchzuführen nein das Entscheidende ist
wir müssen sehr klar sagen wir können
der Ukraine nicht zumuten auch übrigens
uns selbst nicht dass die Ukraine
neutral ist dass sie auf Gebiete
verzichtet denn russland hat sehr klar
gesagt nach dem Fall der Ukraine die
sollte bis 7 März fallen geht es an
Moldau und dann an die bayerischen
Staaten um Sicherheitsgarantien gefragt
hat Putin sehr klar gesagt Abzug der
Amerikaner aus Europa Austritt der
Staaten des ehemaligen Warschauer Paktes
aus der nato-status vor 97 und von
diesem Kriegsziel ist er nicht
abgewichen wir müssen eigene Ziele
definieren und unser Ziel muss sein die
Ukraine ist Teil der Europäischen Union
in ihren Grenzen von 91 und Russland
muss hier Zugeständnisse machen sie sind
doch der Aggressor ja und deshalb
Lohn der Aggression kann ich die neue
Qualität
noch der Lohn der Aggression Russlands
kann nicht den Neutralität und die
gebietsabtretung der Ukraine sein das
darf nicht Schule machen und dagegen
verwehre ich mich auch wenn das ist das
Fatale Signal aus verloren und sowas
redet und dass eine Adresse noch nicht
belohnt werden kann dann bin ich
theoretisch dabei aber praktisch würde
das heißen wir brauchen eine politische
Strategie zu einem vertretbaren Preis
wie wir das erreichen können und das
sehe ich nicht wir haben erreichen
können ohne in einen großen Krieg mit
Russland zu haben ich nicht will und
wovon ich auch unterstelle dass sie
niemand hier wollen kann
kurze frage ich verstehe langsam warum
auf dieser Demonstration noch keine
einzige ukrainische Fahne zu sehen war
weil die Ukraine spielt ja keine Rolle
um wie geht's da gar nicht doch wir
reden doch jetzt die ganze Zeit und
reden
könnte was Putin an dem Punkt bringen
könnte dass er sagten machen wir mal so
und vor allen Dingen reden wir darüber
was wir tun müssen damit uns nichts
passiert und ich will noch mal ganz
deutlich sagen ich nicht dass jeder
Eindruck entsteht wir gehen jetzt hier
alle irgendwie auf sie los um Gottes
Willen ich verstehe und teile und
ehrlich gesagt nerven mich das auch
mittlerweile
bei der Position von jemandem die Frau
Wagenknecht das sozusagen immer so
subkutan mitkommt ihr seid ja alle nicht
für Frieden jeder will das jeder möchte
dass das endlich aufhört das ist doch
gar nicht die Frage also diese Fronten
aufzubauen da sind wir die sozusagen
endlich Frieden wollen und auf der
anderen Seite diese bösen Polizisten die
die ganze Zeit nur Wasser liefern wollen
mir ist das wirklich zu schlicht und
deswegen will ich auch finde das bringt
uns nicht weiter wenn wir hier auch
diese Front aufbauen aber was mich
interessieren würde ist etwas anderes
wenn du keine so wichtig ist darf die
Ukraine das nicht selbst entscheiden ja
sagen wir wollen so ich meine die haben
doch die haben doch das Baltikum vor
Augen ja selber entscheiden natürlich
aber wir haben ja nicht das gleiche
Interessen mit der Ukraine die Ukraine
sieht sich eigentlich schon im dritten
Weltkrieg das sagen
sieht sich eigentlich schon mittendrin
in diesem Krieg und wenn es nach der
Ukraine gehen würde dann würden deutsche
Soldaten an der Befreiung am Dom was mit
kämpfen die NATO in den Krieg direkt
involviert werden dass wir die Ukraine
pur sozusagen und wir haben andere
Interessen weil wir abwägen müssen
zwischen der Unterstützung der Ukraine
wir sind immer wir Deutschen wir sind
wir Deutsche oder wir politischer Westen
wir wollen nicht das ist das erklärte
Ziel der Amerikaner der NATO der
deutschen der Franzosen aller nicht in
einen Krieg mit Russland geraten und das
ist schwer zu balancieren die Ukraine
unterstützen aber wollen nicht in einen
Krieg mit Russland geraten und aus dem
Grund beteiligen wir uns ja auch nicht
mit eigener natursoldaten das heißt im
Prinzip lassen wir doch die Ukraine in
einer Art Stellvertreter Krieg für uns
für unsere Rhetorik dort kämpfen und
auch deswegen sagen die Amerikaner
Spieler leider an der unruhliche Rolle
ich würde sagen schon unter der
Administration von Joe Biden bei Trump
war das anders und wenn sie Trump sich
anhören das wissen sie alle hier was der
gerade für eine Rhetorik macht mit mir
wäre das so nicht passiert und so weiter
ich teile das nicht unbedingt aber
unbedingt unbedingt
also ich glaube Trump ist eine pauschale
Aussage die sie von mir nicht
unterschreiben die und die ich nicht
unterschreibe aber an diesem Punkt hat
er insofern recht als mit dem Wechsel
von Trump zu beiden der Zug der Ukraine
in Richtung NATO-Mitgliedschaft Fahrt
aufgenommen hat und wahrscheinlich hätte
Trump das anders gespielt so und das ist
alles in Deutschland aber egal
genau
was dazu kommen wir gleich bitte ähm
mehrere Ebenen zum einen ähm würde ich
sagen was hier noch gar nicht gesagt
wurde ist dass das was Waffenlieferung
ja gerade tun ist der Wunsch die Ukraine
zu befähigen selbst zu entscheiden mit
welchen Zielen sie dann an einem
verhandlungsstisch geht also es sollte
auch niemanden das machen übrigens auch
die Amerikaner nicht sagen wir der
Westen entscheiden jetzt über
Territorien die nicht unsere sind das
ist eine Entscheidung der Ukraine allein
und der zweite Punkt aus meiner Sicht
wenn sie sagen man Putin Verständnis
haben es geht aber aus meiner Sicht
putiner nicht allein nur um territoriale
Zugewinne sondern es geht der Putin auch
um eine ganze Identitätsfrage und die
hört nicht mit der Ukraine auf und das
muss man ja auch bedenken wenn man sagt
wie kann dieser Krieg enden und was die
Rolle von Trump angeht wer in uns
vielleicht alle noch an die Bilder als
Trump 2018 war es glaube ich mit Putin
in Helsinki stand bei einer gemeinsamen
Pressekonferenz und seinen eigenen
Geheimdiensten widersprochen hat was die
russische Einmischung in den
Präsidentschaftswahlkampf 2016 betrifft
und ich glaube dass eigentlich Europa
sehr froh sein kann dass nicht Donald
Trump gerade im Weißen Haus sitzt
sondern Joe Biden so wird und dann
Christine Hellberg bitte ich möchte das
gerne ergänzen sehr eindrücklich
ansprach sie sprachen vorhin Erfahrung
von der russischen Perspektive die
russische Perspektive 2008 ist
man verhindert mit Frankreich und der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland ein
beitrittsplan der Ukraine für die NATO
genauso für Georgien und schwächt den
Westen indem man noch im Jahr 2008 am
Eröffnungstag der Olympischen Spiele in
Georgien einmarschiert lässt sich ein
paar Jahre Zeit rüstet nuklear mit
Mittelstreckenraketen auf unter dem
Bruch des mittelstreckenraketenabkommens
das mal Gorbatschow und Regen verhandelt
haben greift 2014 die Ukraine an friert
den Konflikt ein verhandelt mit
Deutschland Nord Stream 2 um dann als
man merkt dass die Freiheitsbewegungen
in Weißrussland und auch in Russland
stichwortener Wahlen die Überhand nehmen
greift dann noch mal den Krieg auf und
glaubt innerhalb kürzester Zeit die
Ukraine angreifen zu können die
russische Perspektive ist wann immer
Druck gemacht wurde schrill und laut und
Forderungen gestellt worden ist der
Westen eingeknickt oder hat ein gewisses
beschwichtigungsverfahren eingeleitet
wie sarkozi und Merkel oder wie holende
und Merkel die Amerikaner und Briten
haben 2014 Deutschland und Frankreich
gebeten gemeinsam dafür zu sorgen dass
die Ukraine bewaffnet und militärisch
ausgestattet wird das wurde abgelehnt
die deutsche Antwort war Nord Stream 2
um Russland nicht zu provozieren das
heißt es hat er nicht als Beitrag zur
Deeskalation gesehen sondern als
Einladung zur weiteren Eskalation und
die hat er dann gemacht und dann haben
wir ja selbst im Sommer letzten Jahres
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland der
Bundeskanzler äußerst zurückhaltend das
Thema panzerlieferung behandelt und die
Chance hat Russland nicht genutzt
sondern sie hat weiter eskaliert über
30.000 zivile Ziele zerstört wenige
hundert militärische von Julien nur bis
November und damit will ich sehr klar
sagen dadurch dass das die verhaltene
Reaktion des Westens in der Lieferung
der Ukraine gewesen ist hat Russland
sich bestätigt und eingeladen gefühlt
weiter zu eskalieren und deswegen sind
die Waffenlieferung eben kein beitragen
das ist der Fehler in dem manife zu
Eskalation sondern zur Stabilisierung
der Ukraine um einen politischen Prozess
einzuleiten ist das sicherlich der
richtige Weg noch ein
tun nicht alle Kriege werden mit
Verhandlungen gelöst der Zweite
Weltkrieg wurde nicht mit Verhandlungen
gelöst der Korea Krieg nicht der
Afghanistan Krieg auch nicht und der
Irak Krieg auch nicht deswegen sind
Verhandlungen dann mit einem Verlierer
oder sonst wie dran wir müssen schauen
dass die Ukraine in eine
Verhandlungsposition gebracht wird die
ihnen Russland genommen hat denn die
Verhandlungsposition war Verzicht auf
die Krim Verzicht auf die besetzten
Gebiete wir hatten das alle schon mal
und im übrigen auch Verzicht auf die
NATO-Mitgliedschaft dann kann doch jetzt
der Ukraine nicht mehr zumuten dass sie
auf den NATO-Mitgliedschaft verzichtet
angesichts der furchtbaren
Kriegsverbrechen im ahnen dass ein
Waffenstillstand nur zu Erholung
Russlands und zu weiteren kriegen führt